Let's start with a table view
from the iOS Health app.
Here's the table for Health Data.
If we dissect the content view for
each cell, we see a UI ImageView,
a UI Label, and another UI ImageView.
Here in the Maps app,
you can see that as I type,
the table is rapidly being repopulated.
But, the components of the small views,
the magnifying glass icon,
the placement of the text,
those are repeating.
In both Health Kit and Maps, you see
an image here on the left margin.
And, you see the same
font in the text field.
These top views are instances
of the same view class.
The Search bar is a stock
view that we're going to use,
as well, in our practice apps.
If I return to the map of San Francisco,
and
drop a pin on Golden Gate Park, clicking
that pin gives me another table view.
Here the cell separators are similar
to the ones we just saw.
But, there are no image views,
and each cell contains a button.
Here in my contacts, the table cell
views are separated into sections.
But, in this lesson, we're just
going to stick to one section.
Here, in the albums table of the photos
app, we see a similar structure.
But, the smaller views
are formatted a little differently.
The image views are larger, and we see
two labels with custom font sizes.
Stop for a moment, and think about
which of the pixels on this screen
are actually drawn for
the table view, per say.
Because, the screen is filled up
with these smaller repeating views,
the pixels that are being drawn
are contained in the smaller views.
These small repeating
views are called cells,
they're subclasses of UI TableViewCell,
which is a UI view.
Tables tile the cell views
vertically and draw in separators.
Think about the different tables and
their similarities.
What kind of data is necessary
to populate a table?